[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture d'un tel niveau
bonjour patrice carmouze toujours pour
la rend aujourd'hui avec notre invité
jean-françois près bonjour moi j'ai la
patrie ou alors on va parler des pistes
au c'est votre dernier roman
alors dans ce roman d'ailleurs un moment
il ya il ya un des personnages qui a un
à tony monde appelle ça un apte à nîmes
saisir c'est un nom prédestiné par
exemple il y avait un évêque un verset
que ça peut on se dire aumônier
jean-françois près c'est un acte
organisé d'un obtenu dimanche absolument
puisque j'ai fait toute ma carrière
autour du cheval et le cheval qui est un
herbivore se trouve dans son lit le
tunnel le pré le prix que vous avez
commencé votre carrière de chroniqueur
hippique avec le célèbre célébrissime ou
léon zitrone c'est léon zitrone et andré
théron fser skis mais ce qui m'amène à
vous dire d'ailleurs que de me retrouver
ici aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression d'être
un peu dans la peau d'un vieux cheval de
réforme même si je trouve ça très
agréable vous les voulez qu un petit
bout des audits ronde pauvres pour
s'amuser quoi car elle va le dépasser
on trouve à des passeurs car elle est le
départ
une droite et gagnent ce prix d'amérique
devant l and run est revenu de très loin
oscar et elle conserve la troisième
place
revenue de très loin pas du
diable-vauvert bravo vous publiez aussi
des au monde notamment des romans
policiers qui se passe souvent normandie
d'ailleurs vous avez le prix de
normandie de l'histoire normande en
double jeu je viens d'avoir le prix du
polar normand pour les nervures du
cafard dans les régions de casseurs j'ai
eu le prix de la région normandie pour
le jeu je vois la poule oui et le jour
du cafard c'est aussi aux éditions la
joie ni comme comme comme évidemment
épices tôt et d'ailleurs on va retrouver
dans ce roman vos amours au fond il ya
la normandie il ya deux villes y
apparaît il y aura les impôts de golf
que vous aimez beaucoup aussi et puis et
puis ce héros qui est le commissaire
look saber un ses satellites ses sa
exactement leur grammaire c'est ça vire
de l'allemand cessa ralentir oui alors
long de sa mort en fait il est d'origine
alsacienne
donc bon il a un nom germanique
germanophone et ça veut dire
effectivement leur langue ça meurt ça
vient de langmann qui veut dire lent
donc c'est c'est à ça correspond à la
personnalité du maillot en vérité c'est
assez lent nonchalant et c'est sur le
vaisseau petit ventre relativement
important
ancien un bonhomme patelin
qui n'espère pas la méfiance qui va
doucement et quand quand les les gens
mal intentionnés enfin les l'écho des
coupables putatif enfin peu importe ce
qu'en quelque chose à se reprocher le
voit arriver du robot celui là ça va
sauf quand arrive le regard de
lencquesaing leur regard vers qui est
très persan et il a va peut-être chez
les plus perspicaces d'entre eux
susciter la méfiance alors épicerie à
l'orée piste aux épices tôt comme
épistolaire c'est le surnom que donnent
les enquêteurs et notamment votre
enquêteurs donc en chef lanza meurt à
l'assassin et on a un assassin qui écrit
et à qui écrit-il
eh bien il écrit au commissaire
l'alzheimer pour lui annoncer qu'il va
commettre des crimes et l'eau qui va le
mettre au défi malgré ses qualités de
flics qui sont déjà prouvé il apte à le
mettre au défi de le confondre
alors c'est un procédé quand même assez
habile parce que finalement langue
hammer votre héros bien c'est aussi le
lecteur un lecteur qui se met à la place
du commissaire et il progresse ou pas
d'ailleurs comme une enquête n'est ce
pas oui bah tout à fait le bon le fait
d'écrire c'est c'est un petit exercice
de style dans le sens où l'assassin va
jouer avec le avec langue ça meurt en
fait l'homme ça meurt c'est pour ça que
les que les lecteurs et surtout les
lectrices même temps parce que il est
pro bowl en seniors il est il et il est
âgé il est pas beau c'est pas c'est pas
un apollon c'est pas un dragueur
d'ailleurs il a un rapport avec la gent
féminine qui est assez assez distant tu
es célibataire non plus oui ça
célibataire né s'est pas tu sais tu pas
quelqu'un si il est il est relativement
à sexuellement
il est relativement asexuée et c'est
curieux d'ailleurs que les lectrices
l'aiment beaucoup par les femmes
même dans le roman
il ya notamment une jeune policière elle
est très contente d'être avec lui oui
tout à fait parce qu'il ya parce que en
fait en fait la complicité et la le
fluide mais purement intellectuel il
n'est pas il n'est pas du tout fait rire
il n'est pas du tout sensorielle il
n'est pas charnelle encore moins charnel
il est purement intellectuel et en
général ça fonctionne très bien
ça fonctionne très très bien notamment
avec 7,7 jeune lieutenant mais avec avec
les autres femmes en général et avec les
lectrices et alors pour à balai par une
langue sa mère allait les lectrices me
parle beaucoup et j'ai des réactions
comme ça où dd 2 sur l'ailé de sur les
réseaux sociaux ou les les gens
discutent entre eux dans les groupes de
lecture il est souvent question de même
saveur et ce qui était amusant c'est
quand on quand on arrive à la la genèse
de l'examen en fait ça vient de
nouvelles que j'avais écrites pour
fleuve noir et qui est je ne sais plus
comment ça s'était produit face alors
d'un de manière classique lors d'un pont
ou d'un dîner ou d'un déjeuner et puis
j'avais balancé ça comme ça les
nouvelles avaient été lus et puis il
avait été emballé par l'anc sa mère et
est un jour j'avais fait j'avais écrit
une nouvelle qui n'a jamais été publié
d'ailleurs où ça se passait très mal ou
c'était c'est une affaire de moeurs
absolument horrible et langue sa mère
était là dedans
et là et l'éditrice m'avait nîmes enfin
vous pouvez quand même pas donc ça meurt
c'est pas ça comme ça mais on pouvait
pas le mettre là dedans mais là je dis
pardon est devenu le
récurrence de terrain yaya le monde du
cheval
et puis y'a la franc maçonnerie c'est ça
donc on a évidemment parler un peu du
milieu hippique de la normandie mais il
ya troisième élément qui est évidemment
là la franc maçonnerie et très vite on
apprend que les victimes de l'assassin
eh bien ce sont des formations et
l'assassin ils utilisent tous les
symboles de la franc maçonnerie et le
compas les kerr le vitriol puis les plus
compliquées pour moi j'ai compris que
c'était aussi à la lettre voilà alors il
ya quelque chose
non je voulais non je voulais juste dire
qu'il fait effectivement l'assassin
utilisent les symboles de la franc
maçonnerie
alors je ne vais pas déflorer comme on
comme on dit aujourd'hui ce mot que je
déteste mais enfin qui est très à la
mode
dix villes gâcher oui non peut pas
travailler c'est déjà compliqué de leur
discours
mais c'est vrai que ce sont des signes
forts parce que là haut des au début le
premier nom de sa mère ne comprend pas
bon le compas dans les yeux du bon ça
pourrait être
voilà mais après quand il ya les kerr la
question parce que même même si on n'est
pas formation qu'on est quand même un
tout petit peu les symboles de la franc
maçonnerie et on sait que ça a une
signification
après il ya le vitriol il ya là il ya la
bible tout ça ce sont des signes est
d'aider ce sont surtout des armes d un
week end studieux turquie voilà donc
effectivement la hyène piste là que vous
dire un mot des peut-être des trois
victimes parce que c'est quand même des
salles over il ya un ancien jockey qui
est une star des champs de courses mais
qu' un truqueur il ya un éditeur qui
piquent des manuscrits et un médecin qui
pourrait être nommé ministre mais qui a
des pédophiles en fait c'est vraiment
des daims un peu la ligue l'humanité on
sent qu a eu trois c'est le mal incarné
quoi alors là il ya évidemment un
contraste que j'ai voulu faire ressortir
avec avec la franc maçonnerie dont la
finalité
la finalité c'est le progrès de
l'humanité
c'est le donc effectivement on sent les
écoles musées ouais c'est francs maçons
les ordures paris donc là il ya un sacré
quand tu as ça fait encore plus aux
lecteurs ça ça brouille un peu les
pistes
et puis c'est vrai que le dans le monde
du polar de la littérature noire
on est là pour noircir alors évidemment
si vous prenez le milieu des courses que
je connais bien on pourrait tu deviens
pourrait conditionnel me reprocher d'en
avoir donné une image très négative et
on voudrait batelli vers le guide
on a l'impression qu'on veut le milieu
des courses que vous vous décrivez sais
c'est que des trucs à elle serait cru au
départ il faut c'est que c'est vrai nom
existe dans ces noms vous forcer le
trait est un peu non à huy ha vu non
j'ai la force n 3 n'ont maintenant il
faut être réaliste il faut dire la
vérité
essayez d'être totalement objectif le
monde le monde des courses il n'est pas
blanc bleu mais pas plus que les autres
monde du sport est simplement il y à une
antériorité du monde des courses par
rapport à la prise de paris jusqu'à un
passé relativement récent
on ne pouvait parier que sur les chevaux
aujourd'hui on parie sur les hommes et
on s'aperçoit qu'est ce qu'on réalise
que les matchs de foot sont truqués que
les parties de tennis sont truqués qui a
plein de trucs dans les stades et des
combats même des combats de boxe dans
les combats de boxe c'est depuis
toujours parce que là il y avait les
bookmakers
ça c'est encore autre chose des paris
clandestins mais voilà donc le monde le
monde des courses je dirais il n'est pas
plus noir que les autres monde du sport
je dirais même les mondes le monde de
l'argent parce que le sport maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est de l'argent
on n'est plus au temps du baron
coubertin et il n'est pas il n'est pas
plus noir il est il est pas blanc non
plus il est dans cette lignée là
simplement on en a beaucoup plus parlé
parce qu' on ne pouvait pas parié sur
autre chose que les règlements et le
l'écrivain
le romancier de polar il va noircir j'ai
volontairement il va il va pas bien bien
bien souligner la la bassesse humaine
là où elle est un petit peu suggéré on
va en rajouter 3 points simple c'est
normal
rien justement dans le monde des courses
donc vous vous disiez les pronostics il
ya la réalité de la course qui parfois
fait échapper ce pronostic et lorsque ça
une chose pour la construction de vos
romans
il ya la trame que vous établissez les
personnages l'intrigué est est ce que
parfois il vous échappe
ou alors est-ce que tout est construit
comme ça dès le départ très maîtrisée
comment travaillez-vous alors
complètement de manière non pas
complètement mais de manière anarchique
oui oui alors là tu auras des cma
anarchique et c'est ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure
hors micro l influence des personnages
sur l'auteur cesser complètement
schizophrénique le moi je les rares fois
où j'ai essayé de faire une construction
je n'ai jamais respecté n'ai jamais pu
le réaliser et très souvent je suis
parti d'une idée mais vous savez nous
avons vous allez quand même oui vous
savez qu'il me payer quand même
ben oui quand même non mais sérieux un
grand auteur américain grands auteurs de
polars américains jose plus calme et il
ya eu cette phrase extraordinaire je me
demande c'est pas mal contre condamner
quelqu'un comme ça pour écrire un polar
on doit connaître le début et la fin au
milieu en mai ce qu'on veut on se laisse
est en fait si vous voulez plusieurs
fois dans les romans précédents que j'ai
écris pas ce chai lajoinie mais avant je
crois que j'ai j'en ai loupé un ou deux
à cause de la fin j'ai loupé une sainte
2 et quand vous louper une fin dans un
roman c'est terrible parce que ça
reviendrait à faire un très bon plat
vous savez un très beau poisson a
soufflé magnifique avec les meilleurs
ingrédients vous êtes tous respecté la
recette et tout ça car vous ouvrez le
foot ça fout le camp et s'est terminée
ça vaut plus rien et c'est immangeable
eh bien le
le roman c'est un petit peu la même
chose et là maintenant je vais très très
attention à la fin je fais le début je
le connais parce que c'est ce qui me
permet de redémarrer c'est le sait le
starter d'aider des voitures anciennes
savez pour chauffer le moteur est là et
après au milieu alors mais au milieu il
m'arrive de de changer complètement de
d'inventer d'autres personnages de me
faire prendre la main par l'anc sommer
qui me dit non il y apparaît assis deux
parties doivent s direction on lui
complètement sur la création et si
abominable pour ce pour l'entourage chez
auguste vous interromps parce que rester
fois plus de temps alors lisez vraiment
et piste vous allez être passionné
s'adressait c'est vrai qu'on se demande
qui est des rebondissements formidable
épices tôt et puis il ya eu neuf jours
comment s'appelle d'appeler les neuf
jours de cavale qui est aussi le prénom
monde quitte aussi ses aux éditions la
joie dit et c'est jean-françois près
merci infiniment merci nathalie merci
beaucoup merci à vous deux merci
beaucoup
[Musique]